all right what's up everybody my name is
Alan dragu and today I'm going to walk
you through the exact copyrighting
framework that I use for my personal
daily email list almost every single day
I'm talking nine out of 10 emails that I
send use this exact framework so let's
Dive Right In actually before we dive in
if you could take just one minute to go
ahead and like And subscribe to this
channel to this video it helps us so
much and it lets me know that you find
this content very valuable and that you
want me to continue creating free
content like this for you otherwise I'm
going to put everything behind a pay
wall and just assume you want to pay for
everything that I teach which honestly
is not a bad idea you should pay for the
very valuable things that I teach but
this today in this video I'm giving away
what I find is one of the best
Frameworks ever so I can't believe I'm
giving it away for free let's Dive Right
In All right so if you're part of my
email list you know that I do not do
things like everybody else if you
subscribe to other people's email list
for the most most part they send you an
email once a week and they give you like
a list of stuff that is value based okay
here's 10 things that I learned or five
podcasts that I listen to or five
lessons or or 10 books that I'm reading
like they just give you a listicle of
all the things they're learning and
value and all that stuff and it's cool
that's that's fine but that's not how I
do things okay the way that I do things
is completely different and I have found
it to Skyrocket my engagement way more
when I switched to this method in fact
back in the day I I used to do that old
Weekly Newsletter value based thing that
most people do in fact I had a
newsletter called the Sunday 6 and I did
this for about nine months and for nine
months that I wrote the six favorite
things that I ran into that week whether
it was a book or a podcast or whatever
just the things that I was learning that
week and I had a lot of people that read
that thing but once I flipped to this
new method I had a lot more people I'm
talking thousands more people engaging
with the way that I do this style of
copyrighting and so I'm going to give
that away and share that with you today
but before we dive into the framework I
want to clarify one thing that I just
said a second ago is that I went from a
weekly method to a daily method and this
framework can work with both but it
really is helpful when you're emailing
multiple times a week which I do value I
do think if you're emailing like this
people will give you permission to show
up in their inbox every single day so
multiple emails a week you can't do your
little five tips or five books or
whatever that's that's for the weekly
stuff but this is super juicy for
multiple emails a week whether it's 2 3
4 5 6 7 whatever you want to do so yes
this framework is perfect for that now
we're going to break down this framework
right now and I'm going to do it live
with an email in fact one of the best
emails I think I've written at least
response Wise from you guys that you've
told me wow this was incredible it was a
great time and so that's just an example
of this style of email so this framework
that I do every single day is called the
slow framework SL LW slow and what that
stands for is story lesson offer okay
every day I tell a story in my email and
then at uh after the story I give a
little nugget of a lesson and I tie that
lesson to my offer okay so story lesson
offer slow and I'm going to show you
what that looks like what I'm showing
you right now is an Emil called the
airport Fiasco the 3-hour airport Fiasco
and what it is is I told a story about a
very horrendous time that I had at the
airport okay and I'm not going to read
the whole thing because it's about 500
words but just diving into it I started
with many months ago I made a God awful
trip to the airport right off the bat
you know this is a story I started with
a story M many months ago okay place in
timer right that's that's a that's a way
to start a story and then I tell this
story right flying back to Atlanta from
new orle
and if you've ever been at the Atlanta
airport you know this place was a fiasco
frustration flying off the walls okay
I'm having a little bit of fun here mind
you I've been to this airport many of
times but for whatever reason I could
not navigate this thing blah blah blah
and what I do here is I go through this
entire story where I talk about I'm on
one side of the airport where I'm trying
to get back on the shuttle to drive me
to the parking deck to find my car okay
and I I go all the way across the
airport to go back to the entrance where
I took that shuttle off to go back why
get there and they tell me that shuttle
doesn't exist they don't know how I got
here blah blah blah I should go back to
the other side so I go back 2 miles they
tell me they have no idea what I'm
talking about that I should go back to
this I go back and forth about three
times or four times and they tell me to
go down downstairs I mean my Apple I was
wearing an Apple Watch at the day uh
that day but my Apple watch was going
absolutely bananas okay it was like
Steps goal achieve 5K achieve 10K
achieve I mean I was walking all over
the and I was carrying luggage I was
pissed and this this story right here
was just one of the fun ways to do that
and then what I did 80% of this email is
a story okay and when I get down to the
very end of it I teach one tiny lesson
to this story that tiny lesson is
complexity I talked about how the
airport was so complex that I didn't
know where I was going I didn't know
where the shuttle was I barely even knew
how to get back to my car it took me
three hours to get back to my car and
the tiny lesson that I extracted was
sometimes your business your online
personal brand feels like the airport
it's complexity everywhere okay people
don't know what you offer they don't
know how many products you offer your
product pyramid they don't understand
what you're offering when you're
offering what you write about what you
talk about and there's just complexity
all over the place so what I did in my
SLO framework was I spent 80 to 90% of
the time on the story 10% of the time on
the lesson okay this is an important
factor right here especially as as you
see the way that I write the story
should be so entertaining so fun that
people are willing to read it again
tomorrow that's part of that daily email
factor is you're actually buying
permission for them to open your email
again tomorrow and say that was so fun
that was so entertaining yesterday and
you're not actually hard selling uh
opposed to what many classic copywriters
say I almost never Hard Sell in my
emails because humans are so inundated
with marketing nowadays and with
advertising that they're they actually
repel hard sales pretty hard okay and so
what you're actually doing is you're
buying value and entertaining okay
you're wetting the appetite and then the
last 50 words is an offer where I talk
about the complexity of business and I
say if you want a stupid simple business
using my arm framework my armm framework
that I talk about in lessons 1 3 and six
in my right published chill course you
can go and click the link below to
rubish show.com okay but that SLO
framework I use every single day gets a
ton of responses and it's super fun
because it keeps your antennas up for
telling the best stories that you can
possibly tell makes you a better
Storyteller it gets you more sales and
it's just way more fun to write so I
hope that was helpful for you if you
like the SLO framework and want even
more examples of what that looks like
you can go to my website and read all of
my emails Allen dru.com
and that would be really really helpful
and actually when you land on the
website you might get a popup that says
get copyrighting Catalyst for free
copyrighting catalyst is 63 cash cow
tips that I put together over the last
couple years that will help you make
more money with copyrighting I can't
believe it's free one day I might just
slap a big old price tag on it but for
today it is free you can go grab it put
your email in and I'll automatically
send it to you as soon as you put your
email in so enjoy that and I hope to see
you on the next one